okay the first tendon reflex we're going
to check is the bicep tendon and the
bicep tendon is located below the bicep
muscle in the antecubital fossa area if
you're beginning out what you want to do
is you want to find that tendon so to
find the tendon we are going to have the
patient flex the arm and flex the bicep
and you will find it right in there and
it feels like a cord like area and
whenever you find it just put your thumb
over it and this is going to elicit the
response of c5 to c6 so I have my thumb
over the tendon area and I'm going to
have him relax the muscle and just drape
his forearm over his lap and then I'm
just going to hit with my hammer briskly
and what you're looking for is
contraction of the bicep and flexion of
the forearm and we had a little bit of a
response and there we go okay so that is
how you check that deep tendon reflex
now check out my other videos on how to
check the other for deep tendon reflexes
and consider subscribing to this YouTube
channel